this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money
your life your relationships everything
all of it
we have a packed house here in nashville
tennessee it's good to see everybody and
we are taking your calls on life on
everything eight eight two five five two
two five i'm john dalone joined here
with my good friend george campbell and
we're gonna take all your calls about
any and everything all of them we can't
stop them from coming through
we could we do what we're told
you are correct
this is james show and we do what james
says because we're in james world that's
right you doing well man i'm doing great
how are you seeing you in a minute it's
been a little bit and i'm excited
because we have an event this weekend
and we are tag teaming this talk
together i'm really excited about tag
team back again that's that's before
your time yeah no recollection as to
what you're referring to yeah
you will improve your life if you get
into some old hip hop but you'll get
there you'll get there thank you i'm
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to wayne in birmingham
alabama hey wayne what's going on
brother
hey uh
i just had a qui i'm an over-the-road
truck driver and currently i'm just a
company driver but i'm wanting to
get my own truck and
be an owner operator
but i'm currently on baby step two so i
i'm just toying with the idea of whether
i should
put baby step 2 on hold because i want
to be able i want to pay cash for my
truck and build up the funds that i need
to start my truck driving
business and everything so
let me ask you this wayne what does it
cost to start this business
um well i
i don't
i don't really have all the figures as
far as a total i know
at a minimum it's going to probably cost
between 40 and 60 thousand dollars just
to get a
to get a used semi
with it's got decent miles and
everything on it so that's what that's
what i'm currently looking at getting a
semi that's just a few years old that
you know maybe around 500 000 miles on
it why do you want to move jobs man
uh i i just
i just i have i just want want to be
able to have more freedom as far as you
know i'm not real
i don't have to take i'm i'm the one
that's choosing the loads that i take
i choose where i want to go and when i
come home and those kinds of things just
more
more freedom as far as
my day-to-day life goes i guess gotcha
well if i'm in your shoes i want to get
rid of this debt so i cannot have this
business be a huge stressor in my life
as i'm trying to kick it off and i
especially don't want you starting this
business off with debt which is going to
be hard to do when you're trying to cash
flow this expensive truck and you're
trying to pay off your debt it's just
you're going to be doing too many things
at once how much debt do you have
uh probably i think around thirty
thousand okay what kind of debt is that
uh student loans student loans okay and
what's your income
this year i'm probably looking at
probably around 80 or 90. okay that's
great well you got a great income uh
comparatively to your debt load i think
you can clean up this debt within the
year and then start saving up for this
truck i don't know where you know where
the urgency is coming from to start this
business tomorrow i know you're itching
to do it because of the freedom that you
talked about but i think you're going to
actually feel that financial peace and
feel that freedom when you get out of
debt you have the emergency fund and
then we can start saving up for that
truck and start this business
what's yeah what what's the emergency
brother
i mean it's not really an
emergency or anything i just
i guess i just feel the itch to have my
own truck and with all the freedom
things i was talking about yeah i almost
at the same time i was sort of feeling
the same way as far as the debt i i
really wanted that initially when i
started thinking about it i i really
wanted to be out of debt
because i don't i just want to be free
of all the debt before
starting a business i just feel like i
have a lot
i won't be as stressed in the busine on
the business side if i know
if i don't have a whole lot of debt
sitting out there exactly
yeah i
i love the idea of you using this desire
to
jump jobs
to spend a year
figuring out what the loads are going to
look like what your routes would be
finding a good taking time to find a
good truck and in the meantime just
using this as jet fuel to get that 30
grand paid off so that you can buy this
truck and you owe nobody anything and
it feels like your you're fantasizing
about the freedom you're gonna feel when
you own your own small business
you have no idea brother what it's gonna
feel like when you owe nobody nothing
and you have a paid for truck and you're
running your own loads and then you are
free to run man but thanks for the call
brother let's run what's up dude how can
we help
all right so i got a kind of a unique
situation um
i graduated about a year ago i'm a
full-time travel nurse
uh i been driving the same car it's like
a 2005 versa for at least five or six
years and it's kind of getting come to
my attention that i've gotten to the
point where i've driven into the ground
um
i don't want a new car i would drive
this car if i could
um so i'm not definitely not looking for
an excuse to get a new one
but since i travel i move about every
three months
with travel nursing because i work off
of contracts and where i go where the
money is
i'm about 70 000 in debt which i'm
working through
um
and i make
i'm trying to think right now
with the current contract i'm on i make
about 4 000 a week
so i'm just trying to figure out with
the the current
used car situation because i've been on
used car lots looking for used cars and
trying to trying to find something
that's reliable enough where
i can
drive it
cross state lines and
lug all my life with me and not be back
in the same situation i am here in six
more months if i bought something that
was about
like three grand or even if i can find
something like that i'm just kind of
looking for some direction on what i
should do
so you're making you're making four
grand
a week
so
yeah right now with this contract yeah
so what's your what's your annual take
home it's about 150 i know like if you
if you signed a contract every time
that'd be about 190 what's your what's
your overall picture about 150 this year
uh right now yeah 1751 yeah around there
because i because a lot of it's not
taxed because it's a housing stipend yep
so i take home i take home about 3 300 a
week
okay all right and your housing costs
are covered too
uh no that's part of it so i uh without
getting super deep into it i still pay
obviously it's a little bit more of a
premium because i do airbnb and stuff
like that okay usually i try to stay
under about like 1500 a month of
wherever i'm at which i've been able to
do for a while okay and then i have i
have to for tax reasons i have to have
another house back in
in virginia um that i pay a room rent to
show
just for a weird travel tax reason
very cool so i want to get into this
because there's several things here that
i want to dig into
so we're going to run up into a break
here and want you to hang on the line
dalton and we'll when we come back we're
going to george is going to dig into the
financial side of this and there's some
bigger picture questions i want to walk
through with you too brother but thanks
for the call we'll be right back
george
i love being on the show with you man
it's a blast all right hey give us a
call eight eight two five five two two
five we'll be right back on the ramsey
show
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
this is the ramsay show i'm john dalone
joined by george campbell we are taking
your calls on money life relationships
all of it triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're going back to
dalton in virginia dalton is a traveling
nurse
and he is wondering about a car
this car is as he says come to his
attention that he's running into the
ground so dalton
what does come to your attention mean
did it make an announcement just said
and your brother does cars do that i'm
tired
so yes i've been fixing cars with my dad
since i was a kid so i've done all my
own repairs all my own oil changes and
everything and tried to stay up on the
maintenance and it's just gotten to the
point where it's come to
the the repairs that i'm finding that
our deck
and my heart are on the horizon are
going to be more than what the car is
worth i mean the car cannot be worth
more than 15 hundred dollars and
there's some rattling and some things
going on and some stuttering that makes
me think it's transmission and things
that it's like
and it's also just not reliable being
the fact that i'm
miles away from home um and i i it's i
love my whole life in it everywhere i go
either every three to six months
something like that so i'm just worried
that i'm gonna be on the way to work one
day and
it just
like crashed out of me and then that
would be put me in a situation where i
would be like okay i don't have time to
look for a new car used car so i have to
go buy a new car and i don't want to
have to
have to do that especially with the used
car situation right now because of it
and
the i guess the semiconductors and them
just being not very available right so
i'm going to turn over to george but i
will say anytime in my life all right
i won't project this on to you but
anytime in my life
i quote unquote feel things in my heart
that are on the horizon
that would sure be more comfortable if i
went ahead just did it now or
sure would just you know i'm gonna go
ahead and just buy that now
is often me projecting a worst case
scenario just because i make x number of
dollars and i think i should be driving
a card looks like this
or sure i i
i can invent problems that i could just
solve right now with a click on amazon
or with a new car with the new fill in
the blank
and um so georgia walked through the
numbers with you but
as a mechanic as a guy who knows cars
and also a guy who loves cars
i'd love to hear how honest you are with
yourself about could this car make it
another 12 months in time for you to
take this extraordinary salary and blow
this debt out and then go get another
car of it go ahead george yeah i'm with
john there and i do think you can cash
flow this thing with your incredible
income but i do want to know how serious
are you about getting rid of this debt
the 70 000 are you currently paying
extra on this
oh yeah so um right now i
have probably turned it was about 110
over the year um and i wasn't i wasn't
making my first year nursing i wasn't
making anywhere near this money just
because i was only making about 60.
and then i've only been travel nursing
for about three months so this is it's a
lot of money that i've never had before
and instead of being irresponsible that
i'm using as much as i can to um to just
kind of really get through this so i can
be debt-free um i have i mean don't be
mad at me i know in the babysitter i
should only have a thousand i have
because of my unique situation about 10
grand in the bank um and the reason why
is just because at any point
a company can just pull my contract and
that could be
just out of luck and i have to look for
a new job right then so it kind of makes
me feel uncomfortable only having a
thousand dollars as an emergency fund
just because i would still have rents to
pay and obviously i'd have to find
another job which wouldn't be super hard
right then but it just kind of so you
sign a contract with a company and you
go halfway across the country to work
that contract and you sign a lease
and they can just pull it i thought that
was the point of a contract
yeah so it would
they have a buyout whatever reason
as far as i know know i work so i work
with a travel agency and then they ask
me where i want to go and they send me
all these contracts and how much they
pay
and then i apply to them and they but i
have heard horror stories at a moment's
notice they get a text message that
morning or an email of other travel
nurses and they're like hey your
contract has been avoided and i mean i
don't know how frequent that is like i
said i'm pretty new to it but i just i
hearing that i never want that to be the
case and then i'm like
and from what i've talked to with my
recruiter she's told me like hey if that
ever did happen we would kind of
like move mountains to try to get you
another job in a hospital close to where
you already have a lady
okay um
yeah so
well i'm excited that you have some
savings that makes me feel better about
this situation because if i'm you i'm
taking some of that savings that you
have and just buying a car that's
reliable don't go crazy and i don't
think you are you've got a great head on
your shoulders you're a real
hard-working dude and i want you to take
advantage of this time that you are
making buku bucks and pay down this debt
which you can do with well under a year
with this income and you can cash flow
this car from your savings and once
you're out of debt then you can go wild
go get that six months emergency fund
but right now
it feels like there's just a lot of fear
in your life
and when you get rid of those student
loan payments you're gonna sleep a lot
easier at night because you're not gonna
have payments coming out you're gonna
have less expenses to cover
so if i'm you i'm taking maybe three or
four grand fine you're great with cars
so it doesn't worry me you're gonna
inspect that thing you'll be able to
keep up with the maintenance guess it
doesn't matter get a honda or toyota if
you're driving a lot we talked about
this on the show yesterday
even if it has a hundred thousand miles
those things will go three four hundred
thousand dollar
miles if you if you take care of them
which you obviously do so that's what
i'm doing uh and i'm take whatever the
rest is in that savings account other
than a thousand dollars put it towards
the debt and use that healthy fear to
then fuel you to get rid of these
student loans with this amazing four
grand a month you have coming in while
you have it because you probably won't
have it forever four grand a week four
grand a week
16 grand a month you have coming in dude
you could crush this debt in six months
if you keep up these contracts and you
can cashflow this card today and you're
gonna be in a much better spot i don't
want you to live with paranoia about
what's gonna happen with this contract
and what's gonna happen with this car
that's just not gonna be a fun way to
live your job is already stressful as it
is hey dalton this is normally when i
would take another call but can i ask
you one personal question
yeah absolutely what kind of what was
your financial situation growing up
um so my parents were not
to the point where they are now well off
until i was well out of high school and
into into college um
my my dad was an e1 in the military had
me and my brother my older brother
really young around 18. so it would have
been like a two-bedroom apartment in san
diego
and my mom always tells a story about
like
having to
like have cloth diapers because they
couldn't afford diapers so there you go
um so definitely uh yeah
almost exactly i mean that was my guess
yeah you now have work your butt off
to get to a place
where you have the credentials and
you're leaning into the experience
and you're willing to travel
you're a hard worker and you must be
good at what you do to make that kind of
salary
and you're willing to go where the work
is
so what i want to tell you is there's a
part of your brain that is still living
in
we can't afford diapers
that's how you were raised that's the
world you know
and if you grow up the son of a first
responder of a veteran or a daughter i
mean a kid of there's also this
understanding that any day this all
comes crashing down
right that's the that's the that's the
ecosystem your brain is scanning on a
daily basis
i want you to begin practicing and
whether you get a group of friends into
this and it's gonna be tough because
you'll be on the road whether you get a
counselor whether you do that um an
online counselor through betterhelp.com
whatever that looks like i want you to
begin to lean in and practice
i'm good
i'm stable
i have a great career and i work really
hard
and at any moment could this come
crashing down yeah is it going to
probably not
and if you spend your life in fight or
flight which you've been in for 20 25
years now
you're gonna burn yourself out and
you're gonna always be looking for the
next thing the next scary thing the next
scary thing the next scary thing and
you're gonna be lugging seventy thousand
dollars for the student loan debt around
with you because you're gonna be buying
the next thing getting the next thing
just stop you made it man
congratulations you're a stud dalton
welcome thank you did you hear that
yeah i appreciate it and i want you to
like as george said the challenge here
for sprinters for high achievers for
people who are used to crushing it
people who are used to running their
whole lives from we can't afford
groceries
and
hey dad works in a job he may not come
home every single day
those folks often
spend their life catastrophizing running
sprinting ah
and the baby steps are hard because
they're methodical and they're slow and
they're every single day and they're
every single day and they're every
single day
like george said crush this death get it
out of your life and begin to breathe
and sleep and laugh from your guts for
the first time in a long long time
thanks for the call dalton this is the
ramsay show
so
we are back on the ramsey show triple
eight eight two five five two two call
five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five a lot of numbers in there john
listen my brain said we're done with
numbers we're just gonna go right to
words and uh i was still talking triple
h five five two two five and
most importantly i'm looking up to the
lobby and on the debt-free stage i see
two extraordinary people we got cheryl
and her son his son tyler from anchorage
alaska
debt-free are we are we debt-free we are
debt-free congratulations
welcome to nashville so
how much you pay off
125
632
and 92 cents
wow not that we're counting every penny
125
632 how long does this take you to pay
off 30 months
30 months wow what was your range of
income during this time between 80 to
145 000. 80 to 145 incredible what was
the jump in income about i worked
massive amounts of overtime and in the
middle of this i open my own financial
coaching business goodness you're a rock
star way to go and so it is
did you sell some stuff how'd you get
here no that that doesn't count the
stuff i sold that is what i paid in cash
working massive amounts of overtime
running my financial coaching business
and living on a budget you cashflowed
this whole thing through your income and
side hustles and all the extra work yes
sir wow
that's this is incredible so take us
back 30 months ago what in the world
happened um i went through a divorce
okay um knew that we had to change a lot
of things and we did
um
so you left this divorce with 125 000 in
debt like i said it was more than that
but that's what we paid off in cash we
sold a bunch of stuff we sold vehicles
got rid of houses things like that okay
um and then in the middle of this murphy
was not nice um the gentleman i was
dating
we were planning on a future together
and we found out he had terminal brain
cancer and he passed away six weeks
later oh no
um but when i knew this worked was the
day after he passed away i blew a tire
on the highway during 65 and it was not
a crisis in the middle of my life being
unshambled it was not a crisis wow that
puts things in perspective huh yes
wow and so you come out of a divorce
which we talk about all the time as
though and it's it's common experience
we undersell what a
hard season that is yes that is a tough
tough season
and you transitioned out of that and you
said you looked at this extraordinary
young man sitting next to you and said i
gotta make some major changes how did
you get connected with this crazy crew
uh my parents did dave ramsey years and
years ago they're now baby step
summoners living life um
and i just connected with that and ran
with it i knew it worked i'd seen it
work
so what type of debt was this
you mentioned cars and houses what type
what type of debt was 125 000 student
loans vehicles
um credit card debt unsecured personal
loans
you name it it was there so you were
basically normal yes
normal normal normal wow
so
i
you're extraordinary just in the two
minutes i've known you thank you
so often somebody comes out of trauma
like this on top of other trauma
and they simply turtle up
where did the fire come from the spark
come from that you walked out of this
divorce and said this all changes this
is on me and you you lit the the fire
with jet fuel i have spent 30 months
trying to figure out
what god genuinely put me on this earth
for and i was not going to hide under a
mattress a bed whatever
life is to live
and god has got me through this whole
thing ups and downs trails tribulations
he's got me wow
wow wow wow so
your parents
you you had it back in the back of your
head somewhere that dave ramsey some guy
in tennessee blah blah so you got on the
plan
then what happened
i i ran for it i figured out how to
budget real quick love the every dollar
app
and there were a lot of no's there were
a lot of getting up at three o'clock in
the morning to take him to daycare but
we were gonna do this and we were gonna
do it as fast as i could because i
wanted the freedom and when you're in
debt you have no freedom
so what was this like for you tyler
i don't know
hey that's fair that's fair
um okay so who are the people who
thought you were crazy in your life oh
my everybody where i work thinks i'm
crazy they're like you can't do that i'm
tired of working overtime and trust me i
was tired i'm a single mom i was tired
yeah where do you work where's your day
job i'm a correctional officer
oh wow so your correction officer coach
what are some other uh side projects you
did
um my volunteer accomplished amount of
time at his school we volunteer within
our community there's a place called my
house that's a
homeless team resource center
we feed into them
um
i am we do santa cop and heroes in our
community which helps singers during
christmas time
you're just genuinely an extraordinary
human being thank you hey tyler you
realize you won the lottery with this
one right
yes
your mom's pretty amazing pretty amazing
who are your biggest cheerleaders uh
really my parents my brother as well but
my parents were behind us every step of
the way that's incredible so have you
had the moment where
hey have you got to drop off some of
these jobs
and just get down to one or two um i've
cut my overtime down okay but i still do
financial coaching which i love feeding
in being a ramsay coach is awesome
have you had that moment where
you don't owe anybody any money and
the checks deposit and you're looking at
this
this money in your account saying what
do i get to do with this i have i have
tell everybody what that's what that
feels like
i don't even know how to describe it you
look at all this money and you're like
wait like now i have to give that dollar
a name where's it gonna go um currently
my emergency fund and then obviously
traveling to nashville
that's incredible yeah i love that you
know sally mae's name is not on those
dollars anymore it's cheryl no that's
huge tyler yeah towards your dreams i
mean this i'm just impressed because i
feel like i i make excuses john i don't
even have kids
my wife is working here and i feel like
i don't have time to volunteer and she's
out there side hustles coaching
volunteering all day long while keeping
this day job how did you do it are you
the type of person who just doesn't make
excuses
um there are times for sure in the
middle of this i made a couple of
excuses but really i knew that if i
could stay focused
there was essentially light at the end
of the tunnel
and really the
volunteer opportunities they do on the
side feed into me
they encourage me they build me up and
so that's what i needed in the middle of
working all these hours to see that
there are people that don't have the
opportunities i have
and so to be grateful for the ones i do
that's amazing well you are
a rare gift and the people driving down
the road right now who've been kind of
considering this or thinking about it
you just took away every single excuse
they might come up with and i hope
you'll enter a season of
rest and if dreaming of what's next and
what can be right
this type of
gazelle intensity is extraordinary
you've changed your family tree in 30
months right and this young man next to
you he doesn't talk very much but he
absorbed every second of it and he
understands what an extraordinary woman
his mama is how strong brilliant and
capable it's incredible you've changed
his life too and we applaud you for that
we're gonna give you a copy of the
legacy journey because that's the next
step you are on the road to being a baby
step millionaire and you can probably
get there with just two or three of your
18 jobs that'd be great
and we're also going to give you a copy
of total money makeover so you can give
to somebody else and you can pay this
one forward
thank you for inspiring us all
what a gift so cheryl and tyler from
anchorage alaska paid off 125 000
in 30 months making 80 to 145 000
this is the moment you're waiting for
count it down ready
three
two
one
there he is
i knew it was in there john there he is
he was just waiting for his moment
tyler was waiting for his big moment and
there it was it was all that pent up now
finally we can go to a restaurant
i love it what an incredible incredible
woman i mean goodness gracious that just
that makes my day i can't help but smile
seeing that that family right there and
seeing that legacy change the family
tree changed because someone decided you
know what i can make some sacrifices for
30 months in the midst of trauma in the
midst of going through a really hard
season because this stuff matters and my
freedom is more important
my
my take 30 months
go through
hell and back
and we're going to change everything
nothing's stopping her now nothing
absolutely nothing what a gift cheryl
this hey if you listen to this
that could be you too
you can say no more i'm done
okay 24 months 30 months change
everything
what a gift this is the ramsay show
how many times in the past year have you
heard someone say i wish things would
get back to normal
let's be honest what was normal like for
you
worried about money stress too much to
do not enough time to do it
you shouldn't have to go back to that
when there's so much better ahead for
you
but to get the life you want you need
the right game plan you can't just run
out in the field like a maniac you gotta
have a plan so join us for game plan
live our free live stream on september
28th this costs no money free plan
game plan live on september 28th dave
ramsey christy wright and george cam
will be laying out the clear plan to
make all your money goals
come
true
like how to find a vision that gets you
excited how to set healthy boundaries to
keep you focused and how to take control
of your money so it can start working
for you you can have the abundant
balanced debt-free life you want and it
all starts with game plan live to
register for the free f-r-e-e free live
stream text game plan to 33789 that's a
game plan all one word to three three
seven eight nine all right let's go to
suzanne out in spokane hey what's up
suzanne
hi there
hi there how's it going i just love that
it rhymes suzanne and spokane it just
made me happy it's good to have you
suzanne how can we help you
good thank you guys so much for taking
my call you got it what's up um
so
this is basically what i've got
so my husband and i we moved up we're
actually in the north idaho area so
we're just kind of over the border from
spokane
we moved here really unexpectedly last
year after my husband lost his job and
it just ended up being such a blessing
he got a job up here
and we absolutely love it
and we don't want to leave we're closer
to family now and he got a good job here
he's been able to start a business so
he's actually working two jobs
and i am a stay-at-home mom now we've
got two baby girls
congrats and
so thank you so it's really expensive
here that's one thing we didn't know we
didn't know the area that well but we
love it so we're determined to stay here
and we were actually able to pay off all
of our debt last month
wow congratulations super exciting
yes so in the midst of covet and babies
and this move and everything we still
manage to pay off our debt so we own our
vehicles all that
and we're in a rental but we've decided
that we want to go ahead and buy even
though this market is really crazy and
it's really expensive here
but we figured since we're debt-free we
can go ahead and pull the trigger and do
it so we're in the middle of purchasing
a place that we found so you already
have a contract out
yes we do we yeah we close here in a
couple weeks okay
yeah
so
it is expensive and we know that you
know we had started with a budget that
was a bit lower and we decided to go
higher because we just we found this
great property and it just seems like a
wonderful place to raise children and
since we're dedicated to staying in the
area we wanted to do it so you've laid
the groundwork to justify not making a
smart decision is that what happened
is am i questioning the decision
yeah you've laid the groundwork
to have possibly made a not great
financial decision it sounds like
there's a lot of emotion behind this of
just excitement about getting in a house
and all this so give us some details
about the the financial aspect
yeah
so we when we first started looking so
we've been looking for months and months
with our realtor
and
we didn't have a super firm budget in
mind but we decided around the 450 mark
was we didn't want to go much over that
we thought we could really afford that
and still be able to save money
but in this market and in this area
where we live what you can get for 450
just doesn't even seem worth it these
aren't even really starter homes they're
not even really fixer-uppers and
we just found that nothing in that price
range
we were willing to go for so we decided
that we wanted to not only do a house
but get some property since we've got
little kids
so we ended up finding something but
it's about a hundred thousand more
so five fifty then we initially started
yeah so now we're in the 550 range and
how much are you guys putting as the
down payment what percent
well we aren't because we're both
veterans so we're going through a va
loan so we aren't actually putting
anything down
okay what's your take home
yeah so we are yeah we are gonna finance
the whole thing um
which puts us at about a twenty five
hundred dollar a month mortgage on a 30
year
yes okay yeah suzanne all right what's
your question you're getting us all
fired up i'm getting riled up suzanne
yes how can we yeah well that's what i
would i don't know if we can help your
knee deep in this thing if i'm you i'm
getting out of this thing if there's
still time but you've already signed a
contract so what's your question
well my question is um
should we focus on
saving money because you know we're in
this we're going to be paying this
mortgage should we be saving money and
focusing on that or should we focus the
extra money that we have every month
towards this mortgage and get it down
you should have focused it before you
ever gotten this contract and had a
healthy down payment on a 15 year uh
that's what i would feel better about i
don't love this idea of you guys getting
out of debt and then taking on over a
half million dollars on a mortgage and
thinking that
they're doing you a favor by giving you
the va loan
and is that not a big part of your
take-home pay
what is your take-home payment it is
um right now we've got several different
sources of income what's the total here
here's what's happened suzanne you
have created a universe that you want to
have you want to be in this area you
want your kids in in this area well our
kids need to go ahead and have this too
so you created that as well
and you've created a
really
fungible flexible dollar amount we just
got a lot of money coming from this
place and that place and this place and
here's what you've done you've created a
cloud
that allows you to a not see very
clearly and not have to see very clearly
which allows you to live in a fantasy
and now you've zeroed down in one of the
if not the hottest real estate markets
of all time
so it takes a teeny tiny correction and
you are underwater in a half million
dollar
house working side jobs that are kind of
kind of make decisions you know it and
suddenly this zero down va loan is a
nightmare
because you're underwater
and you can't get out
so tell me how much money you make
how much money comes into the suzanne
and company home
every month
um about
my husband's business is tough we can't
because it's a new business
but about a hundred thousand a year
right now
is that take-home pay or is that gross
yeah
that's take-home
so you're taking home about eight
thousand dollars
right right and your mortgage is going
to be
uh
over
about 31 of your take-home pay is going
towards the mortgage and that's on a
30-year which we never ever ever
recommend we always tell people to do
the 15-year fixed rate but you're here
right but we're here suzanne how old are
you guys
um 35 and 37. okay you've got a lot of
life to live and i want to see you live
it and i don't want to see you drowning
in this giant mortgage payment with
nothing down uh i've i've just talked to
too many people heard too many stories
and they start out like yours
starry eyed about the housing market and
wanting to get in and we want the
property we got to have the yard and the
budget's flexible and we're not putting
anything down
and all of a sudden they can't breathe
yeah and we get calls i'm sure we'll
take one during this show where someone
calls in and says we're in over our head
we put nothing down on this house and
we're drowning
and so if there's time to get out i mean
it's just you sign well you sign the
contract so you sign the contract
i don't know what the situation is there
uh if you're stuck with this thing
you may want to look at increasing
income refinancing to a 15-year and
making sure that you can afford it but
as far as paying down the mortgage i
mean it's a little late for that
conversation
because we're really we're knee-deep in
this thing
but we recommend 10 to 20 down to avoid
pmi or more on a 15 year where the where
the mortgage payment is no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay so so far
every one of the every one of the rules
has been broken which just hurts my
heart because i want to see you guys win
and you've worked so hard to get to this
point where you're debt free and you're
making these decisions and i don't want
to see you step backwards and make a bad
financial decision for your future but
if you're here to answer your question
yes i would treat
the 20 down as the new gazelle intensity
i wouldn't save money i would sprint and
get some sort of cushion underneath your
feet and make sure you have an emergency
fund of three to six months before you
do anything before you start saving
anything right you're under water and
y'all got to get your head above water
first get 20 down on that house pay it
down and get an emergency fund
so now we're in the books we'll be right
back on the ramsay show
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money
and your life your relationships your
marriages boundaries everything
we're here to take your calls triple
eight eight two five five two two five
i'm john dalone joined here by my good
buddy george campbell and we are taking
your calls on everything
george you're doing well i'm doing so
good john nothing brings me more joy
than hosting the ramsay show with you
you're don't carry don't tell dave well
my wife can't host the show john oh i
see what you're saying yeah
so it's a little different i like
hanging out with my kids more than
hosting this show with you that's a fair
point i'd rather be hanging out my dog
right now but we got to work and it's a
good time we get to help people for a
job
that's amazing that is pretty good it's
i like working the show with you man it
is fun i'm glad you're we're a good team
you're great you're great at what you do
and i try so
there it is
oh you are way smarter than me my man
all right let's go to nathan in kansas
city missouri what is up brother nathan
uh thank you dr john for taking my call
you got it what's up
first of all i'm debt free
however i just recently
tapped into a personal mutual fund
for 50k
and i have a two-part question
how much should i set aside for state
and federal taxes
and would i be paying taxes on the full
amount that i took out or just the
dividends
great question so this is the two-parter
you're saying how much did you set aside
should i set aside for state and federal
taxes
tell me about this mutual fund so you
had invested in some stuff just in a
brokerage account this is non-retirement
we're talking about non-retirement it
says something i did personally okay and
what what made you tap into it just
curious i was going to and i'm going to
invest in a rental property
oh okay have you paid off your your
current mortgage do you have one i'm
debt free oh you're dead free including
the house everything yes way to go
hey nathan let's celebrate first have
you have you celebrated nathan you're so
nonchalant david i get up
i love that how old are you man i'm 70.
wow nathan congratulations brother this
is what an accomplishment it can be done
that's so great so let's talk about this
mutual fund so um are you wanting to use
this mutual fund just for the rental
property would you want to just cash it
out and use that as the down payment
essentially
it would just be used for the rental to
purchase a rental property and to rehab
it
okay and i'm guessing that's not going
to cover the full cost you said it has
50k in there
no i i took i took out 50k oh okay
you've got way more in there
right i have more in there but you're
not wanting to pay cash for this
property
no i'm i'm that's why i took out the 50k
to pay cash for the property oh the
property is only 50k including the rehab
cost the
property is about 30k rehab maybe about
15. wow outside that's incredible you
just don't hear about that kind of real
estate these days outstanding yeah i'm
impressed
well you're crushing here so let's talk
about the the tax implications um how
long have you had these mutual funds for
about 20 years oh
okay so you're gonna pay a long-term um
capital gains tax and for 2021 let me
see if i've got the numbers here are you
do you do married filing jointly or
single for taxes
single okay um and what is your your uh
you're cashing out 50k of this right
correct okay and what's your income
70k a year okay so you're probably
looking at uh 15
capital gains tax total so that's what i
would factor into whatever the gains are
so you're not going to pay that on the
50 because not all of that is gains so
do you know how much the gains are
i don't have that uh
available do you do you work with a
financial advisor right now
you know i kind of just listened to dave
ramsey and you guys wow
myself and you've done really well it's
just like that
uh if you want to i would connect with a
smartvestor pro these are investing
professionals in your area in kansas
city who know all the ins and outs for
the state for all that stuff and they
can help you
make a really wise decision with this
but as far as what i'm looking at here
with the bare numbers what's going to
happen is let's say 25 of that was you
and 25 was was growth on that then you'd
pay 25 pay on the 25 000 and it would be
15 of that so that's how much i would
factor you do need to look into what the
gains were on the amount you took out
and then factor 15
and then what did you have a follow-up
um
well i think you've answered my question
oh great yeah i would still i mean if
you're not if you don't have a tax pro
and an investing pro in your corner with
with the amount of wealth that you've
amassed i would do that you can find
both of those at ramseysolutions.com
click on trusted pros i would get in
touch with both attacks pro and an
investing pro because i want to make
sure that you protect what you've built
and it continues to build
as you as you continue this amazing
journey that you've been on fantastic
all right let's go to james in charlotte
hey james what's going on
how are y'all doing today remarkable how
about you man
uh i'm pretty delighted to be honest
with you i'm sorry to hear that what's
up brother so uh me and my wife started
off last year uh during the dave ramsey
plan and uh was on baby step two we had
a hundred and five thousand dollars
approximately of consumer debt
and uh irs debt
and we got that down to about forty
three thousand
and uh hey who lost about eight hold on
let's take real quick you paid off 60
grand in a year
yes
we make uh between 110 to 120 000 a year
okay
i know you're deflated right now we're
going to get to that but i want to take
one second and just say
that's what's up congratulations
that's awesome appreciate it 60
something thousand dollars it's
incredible all right so
i guess this this takes a left turn here
somewhere right
yeah um about six months ago we went
through a dss issue and had to hire a
lawyer and go through all the legal
proceedings with that what kind of issue
what kind of issue i did a dss issue
with my kid okay
and um
so we lost all three of our kids and had
to get them back and
went through all that stuff what
happened
um my kid went to school and basically
used the imagination's imaginative story
and uh
they took it seriously and pursued dss
and
they basically
took us through the winger for no reason
and so dss is the department of job
protective services in your area yes
okay and so they reported some sign some
some sort of abuse of some sort and they
came in and did an emergency removal
yeah okay and then you all went through
getting an attorney and you're fighting
to get your guns back
yep and we did get our kids back about a
month ago or so how long were they gone
from you
um about
two months
okay
i'm sorry to hear that man that's that's
a nightmare
yeah we haven't already got over that
part of it yet and my kids haven't
either they they're not really the same
now either we're going through the whole
counseling thing with them good
so how can we help man
so um i lost that eight thousand dollars
through that process which i don't i
mean like i don't think that's uh like i
would spend another eight thousand
dollars get my kids back
but uh like it just threw me off track
and like uh
like especially with economy now with
inflation like when i do my budget i'm
just not like motivated no more
so
on the back end of the trauma you and
your family have just experienced
you went to fight or flight
you fought for your kids
you went sprinting after them to protect
them you got everybody back in the house
and that snow globe of your home has
been shaken
not having motivation is totally normal
i want you all to grieve this thing
together lean into that counseling and
then you and your wife are going to have
to excavate what was and build something
new because you're a family that's
experienced trauma you've got this
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
825-5225 this is the ramsay show talking
life and relationships and your money
right before the break we took a call
from james in charlotte north carolina
james was
him and his wife were on the same page
and they were just crushing a hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt
and um we ran right up against the break
there james and so i'm glad that you
hung on the line because i want to
circle back a little bit um you guys had
paid off 60 000 in a year
and
for
any number of reasons behind closed
doors there was some conversations at
school with one of your kids and the
child protective services got involved
took your kids away for a while they are
now back but
um you spent a chunk of money 8 000
bucks with attorneys and fighting for
your kids which as you noted you would
have spent 16 you would spend a hundred
thousand i was getting those kids back
in your home but now you're in the
big exhale right things feel like
they're in ash am i right
that's right so walk us through what
what's
what's going on in in your home
um
financially no no no i'm talking about
the spirit of your house right now is
everybody deflated and a little bit
terrified and exhausted and mad and all
those things hurt yeah
a little bit of everything and like
scared of not knowing what to expect
you're always expecting another caller
visit from dss okay and uh what's
happening in that school when he goes to
school i mean it's just what he's going
through and guilt he feels like we try
not to make him feel good about it
but i mean
he's eight years old so he does feel a
little bit and understands a little bit
of the repercussions but not all of it
sure and what about the other kids in
their home are they upset with you guys
with them with everybody
well it was uh another kid involved was
uh five years old and then a
one-year-old okay and uh the
one-year-old we kind of lost a little
bit of bonding time with him and a
little bit development delays because he
wasn't in our care yeah and a
five-year-old just going through a bunch
of separation anxiety yeah
so we're getting them treated for that
as well how long were they gone
um
right at two months two months huh
and normally we don't even go a night
without them but we don't
pawn our kids off and go have fun we
normally just do family stuff all the
time if we're not working yeah
certainly they're not used to being away
from us and we're not used to staying
away from them
and this is one of those hard things
because you're a parent of three young
kids and you as someone who loves your
kids and probably the children that your
kids associate with
you want a group of people that will
kick the door in and protect children
from bad parents right yeah because i
was a foster kid there you go
you want that service and at the same
time you're on the other end of a
misunderstanding
and there's that thank god there's group
people like that out in the world and
oh my gosh what a my family just
suffered trauma major trauma yes
how's your marriage
um our marriage is pretty good if it
wasn't good i don't think we would have
made it through them two months okay
everybody in a marriage after a
situation like this people grieve
differently how are y'all grieving
uh my wife uh took it really hard and i
was more on my anger side so like when
she would cry i would like try to shut
that down man i didn't let her grieve
like i should have be honest with you
okay
um
i just because like if i i felt like if
i would have got to the point of the
crime and stuff like i would have lost
everything and my
emotional well-being and i couldn't let
that happen at the time because i had a
fight ahead of me i couldn't
you know what i mean by my so i don't
think i
went through the grieving process
correctly and i don't think i'd let her
do that as well okay
so um here's what i want you to do
you've got all three kids back how long
have y'all been back together
um i've said a month but i think it's
about two months now cause we went we
just did our family vacation a weekend
ago okay how was that uh it was pretty
good just rushed okay but i felt like it
was uh it kind of
put my kids in a better place
emotionally
so before i start answering questions
that i want to answer what
how can i help you brother
so like i'm like really i could be there
for you tomorrow uh the only thing hold
me back is two vehicle loans okay
and uh where i put myself and then like
when i budget to do that like
david said like now
like i guess because the anticipation of
something coming up now it just
like i can't go all in no more like i
feel like i gotta hold back and wait to
see what else is gonna happen
how honest you want me to be with you
100
okay
somewhere along the way probably when
you were one or two years old
four or five or six or seven or eight
nine or ten years old you learned
i cannot be vulnerable it'll get me
killed
yeah you're a foster kid you still
that still hangs over you like a cloud
sometimes on a bad day is that fair
that's right and at the same time you're
grateful for the people who took you in
that fair
that's great okay so you live in this
toggled world back and forth and back
and forth
and what you have done over the last how
old are you
i'm 36 okay the last
three decades
is you got real real strong
real strong
and in counseling we call it leakage
and that's a dirty diaper term but the
reality is this
you can deal with that stuff
or it will deal with you
it will come out in rage it will come
out in anger it will come out in unable
to take a firm next step and so you end
up just shutting down
and shutting down if you think of like a
like one of those one of those machines
at the dump that crushes cars and just
presses down your feelings and your
emotions and your relationships another
word for that is it will depress
everything
yeah so that's where i'm at that's where
you are that's exactly right so i want
you to know two things number one your
body's working just like it's designed
to
and
you can heal
and you'll be able to take a full breath
again if you choose to
the choice there starts with sitting
with your wife one night after your kids
are in bed
and looking her in the eye and holding
both of her hands and saying
i didn't let you grieve this i didn't
let you cry and i'm sorry
and then following that up with i don't
know how to grieve and cry and i feel
like if i start crying i won't ever be
able to stop
and what you're gonna do it's completely
counterintuitive
to enter a fight on your on your back
right
yeah
and what the only way through this is
through connection and relationship and
the only way to connection relationship
is through being vulnerable and being
honest in saying the words i hurt
i'm scared i'm sorry
and those aren't three words that have
served you well in the past because
you've had to be really tough to
navigate a really hard hard row right
that's right do you love that woman
yes i do you trust her
yes now's a chance to turn it all around
when you connect you'll be able to
breathe you'll be able to sleep for the
first time in four months
that's right and when she says how can i
help you and you're honest with her
you'll be able to breathe and sleep and
when you ask her how can i best serve
you right now how can i help you grieve
because i know we're going to grieve
different and that doesn't mean you've
got to cry on the floor and kick and
scream and write poetry to yours that is
everyone grieves differently
but you got to be honest about what you
need
and then
you can go into the money stuff
but the money stuff is the fear about
the money is a symptom of
a heart that is still in fight or flight
a brain an amygdala that's still burning
bright waiting for the next knock on the
door
you get what i'm saying
yeah and i know i know i know my brother
this is scary and this is all new and
these are these are skills you haven't
used before and so you're gonna have to
practice it you're gonna goof it up and
you're gonna feel awkward and you're
gonna feel scared and you're gonna
backtrack all those things are good but
your wife's gotta know i'm in with you
and that starts with i'm sorry i should
have let you cry and i don't know what
to do and i thought that if i started
crying i would never ever stop
and you're you're not man george so many
of us learned that skill right cover up
man
and stick your chest out and just go out
swinging that's just that's what so many
of us know to do
and it feels counterintuitive it feels
unsafe to back down and look at somebody
and say i'm scared i don't know what to
do next yeah and we're seeing all over
the country man the research on on
leaders who came out during the
last 18 months and tried to flex and
snap into a slim jim their way through
this
they are cracking the people underneath
them are leaving in droves and those
leaders who came out and said i don't
know what's next
we're going to rally around we're going
to work really hard and we get new
information we're going to change our
minds we do things different the people
are staying and they're staying and
they're being successful and they're
pivoting and moving same same thing
works in relationships and it marriages
yeah
it's a hard hard season my brother and
scary and i'm sorry that your family
experiences trauma
healing is up to you and your wife and
it comes today start today brother james
this is the ramsay show
so
this is the ramsey show and on our debt
free stage rob and anna
are here to do your debt-free scream how
much did we pay off uh we paid twenty
six thousand seven hundred and eighty
dollars 26 thousand 784 how long 12
months 12 months where are y'all from
we're from phoenix arizona
12 months how much money are you making
um about 85 now started around 55 when
we started paying off the debt
55 to 85 that's a big jump what happened
um well with pandanamic he lost his job
and so i just started working as much as
possible very cool so what happened 12
months ago that you said enough's enough
let's hit the gas on this thing just uh
you know we took fpu years ago and
lived davish for a long time that kind
of helped us get through like a couple
of weird bumps in you know going to
nursing school
just having weird housing situations
like just
just getting through that but then yeah
12 months ago with a pandemic hitting
and you know we just were like this is
not cool
like trying to go into that hoarding
mode of you know what do we do you know
because just lost my job and it's yeah
you know
save as much and then that might just
sit in there and we still have these
debts so we just started paying yeah you
know so you got spooked you're like very
screwed for sure for sure yep so what
kind of debt was this um it was two
student loans and a car two student
loans in a car all right so take us back
12 months who sat down with who and said
today's the day we make a change um it
was it was always sort of my thing yeah
the head of the organization here yeah
so can i can i um
ask you a personal question yes
so you lose your job
that the the research tells us that the
psychology of a job loss is can be
similar to the loss of a loved one it's
a heavy trauma yeah
um both psychologically spiritually to
that to our ego right yeah
then your wife comes to you and says
i'm we're i'm i'm in charge now right
what about that situation a lot of guys
i've talked to over the years would
turtle up would puff their chest out and
say hey hang on
what about that situation said you're
right let's do this well
never thought that she wasn't right you
know it's not you know pride has to step
to the side whenever you're doing
something like this you know
uh when the pandemic hit the kids had to
stay home too so someone had to be there
anyway yeah and it's kind of it was
like a curse and a blessing kind of you
know very cool to be there you know we
have to do whatever we can do for the
girls it's not just it's bigger than
just us so
and it can be very isolating for anyone
that does go through this yeah
because even if you don't like your job
or you love your job you know that's
social interaction that you're missing
out on that absolutely can be very tough
to replace whenever you have
a six and a two-year-old
you know
i don't know man i know some workplaces
where that's about the caliber of
interaction but yeah i do get that
absolutely um so you get on the program
tell us about the last 12 months
um yeah just working really hard i at
the time that the pandemic hit i had
been working part-time because we had
two kids
and so just working a lot um i did
christy's business boutique
so i had my little side hustle um
repairing american girl dolls and uh i
ended up
gotting getting a lot of business a lot
of people were sitting at home needed
repairs done so tell america what it
costs to get an american girl doll
repaired well um i've done repairs for
up to about 200 dollars for one doll wow
depending on like the age of the doll
what it needed repaired so i had to get
stitches on my live child once for about
200 bucks and i was kind of annoyed by
that yeah that's why wow
that's the way to go getting creative
and doing whatever it took to get rid of
exactly absolutely you guys are
inspiring and so you basically just
flipped roles right i'm crushing it i'm
going to take care of i'll become the
ceo of this house and we'll make it
happen
who's your biggest cheerleaders um my
parents for sure um my mom was the one
who well my parents bought us a fpu you
know years ago when i took it at our
church and
so they've always been you know the for
the forefront for us and i mean just
each other as cheerleaders you know like
i would get exasperated about something
and i mean he's just my rock he's there
for me like he picks me up like we we do
i mean it sounds cheesy but we complete
each other like it's you know god put us
together for a reason so
i really feel like you know it's just
been it's we've been perfect for each
other for that it's just you know one of
the things that's big that we did before
even though we were living dave ish we
didn't i don't personally ever spend a
lot of money i've never had a credit
card my whole life so it's you know just
you know kind of frugal that way but we
do like to eat out and so that's kind of
you know took a back seat you know start
making everything at home from scratch
yeah he learned how to do tortillas from
scratch
tacos
good
wholesome person with integrity and
character does they like tacos right
yeah would you tell people the key to
getting out of dennis
i would just say um you know sticking
together have your person um
make your budget be intentional with it
you know we i read rachel's book and uh
i just
i wondered why am i going to target like
what is the point of being there and
spending this money you know
so just the intentionality of everything
is really what helped you know and just
supporting each other you know it's
because i've always had an issue with
the all or nothing mentality and it's
really easy to be defeated whenever it's
like if it's not working out it's like
we'll just do something different it's
like just have one foot in front of the
other you know how to eat an elephant
one bite at a time you know so dave
always says uh he reads the tortoise and
the hare every year and every year he
reads it the
the tortoise wins every time yeah
um so uh what's it feel like to be
debt-free oh that's amazing that's great
you know like shortly afterwards you
know we had some major car issues which
you know maybe a year ago would have
been who knows what would have happened
you know maybe would have had to turn
that other way and go deeper into that
but you know you get a twenty eight
hundred dollar car repair and it's like
oh we've got them we gotta do that it's
annoying it's not like yeah exactly yeah
fantastic you know so so i see two
little ones sophia and emma you gotta
bring him up on stage
come on girls
come here
mask off please
beautiful beautiful coming from so sweet
you gotta watch because they're wearing
matching dresses and uh america needs to
see the cuteness right now yes
and i know you all know this
but the stress and uncertainty and fear
that y'all faced 12 months ago
13 14 months ago because
you lived like no one else for 12 months
those two beautiful
beautiful little girls will never know
you've changed their entire legacy and
they'll enter into college into their
marriage is debt-free and they'll have a
peace that their peers won't understand
because of the work y'all did this year
i'm so grateful for you guys so rob and
anna and sophia and emma from phoenix
arizona paid off twenty six thousand
seven hundred dollars in 12 months
making 55 to a repairing american dolls
eighty-five thousand dollars
count it down for your debt-free scream
three two
one
that's what i'm talking about
while holding kermit while holding up
she's holding it kermit i bet she could
repair it too i never went down
but she couldn't get 200 for that no not
out of me what an incredible couple
man so george
12 months ago
we were sitting here at the office
i was a little bit nervous what's gonna
happen where are we going the business
going good but running around
take me to your house you and your wife
are sitting down and you have this
conversation and you look up 12 months
later
what's that feeling feel like in your
home man
just freedom i mean like they said when
it comes to these emergencies and the
next pandemic and the paranoia and the
fear you can just suck all of that out
by being in a place where you are
financially free where you have a
foundation set to where nothing's gonna
shake you guys it might be annoying it
might be frustrating but it's not gonna
be a crisis there you go and where
they've set themselves up right now with
total dead freedom with these two
beautiful little girls it just gives me
hope for america and i want everyone to
know that hey where you are right now
doesn't need to be where you end up and
just 12 months could change the next 40
50 60 years and more importantly could
change the next
60 70 or 80 for those two yeah and their
kids and so on and so on and so on one
of my favorite things in a debt-free
screen people you know they get on the
stage and there's cameras in here and
lights and people are a little bit
nervous and they tell their story and it
always comes back
physiologically you can see it on their
body
and
they often will hold hands a little bit
tighter um it it you can feel it on them
and then you ask him that one question
what's it like to be debt-free
and just like these two beautiful folks
they light up everything their shoulders
drop they're
they exhale yeah you have no idea it's
incredible right if you are
vacuuming your house if you're at work
and you got your headphones on if you
are driving your car right now wherever
you happen to be listening to this
feel your shoulders right now feel that
pit in your stomach
just exhale and drop your shoulders
that's peace
that's freedom
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code ramsey to get the
best deal rules and restrictions apply
today's question comes from brittany in
iowa i've worked hard for 17 years to
support my family god recently opened
the door for me to pursue a doctoral
degree with a full scholarship that
covers tuition and a monthly stipend the
stipend is significantly less than my
salary because i have zero debt will be
okay
the problem is i recently found out my
husband has twenty thousand dollars in
credit card debt he also has a hefty car
note he wants me to cash out my
retirement funds to pay off his debt
if he were remorseful it would be
different but he's nonchalant about the
entire situation if i pay off my
husband's debts plus pay taxes on what i
would have to withdraw it will wipe out
half of what i took 17 years to save can
i forgive his financial mistakes and
still not pay off his debts so i can
pursue the doctorate
so brittany here's the
hard reality that you face
your marriage is on life support and it
is about to have a giant split in it
you are taking a hard left turn into a
doctoral degree with a full scholarship
and your husband is living in the past
in what was
and both of you are pretending things
aren't any different yet they are i
don't like you using my money plus his
money and his debts plus my debts it
tells me all are not on the same page
and to commit to a doctorate degree
that's a life right that's a full-time
job and this is going to be a tough road
to hoe without support
much less somebody else that you're
dragging along behind you
so what you all need to do
asap
is you need to go sit with a marriage
counselor
before the weekend is up
sit with a marriage counselor and you
have to be honest
you have to look at your husband and say
i don't feel that you're a person of
integrity when it comes to my money
we're not on the same page here i'm
about to enter into a whole new
adventure and um
otherwise i've just seen too many people
in the situation george they don't come
back from this yeah right and it doesn't
have to be a doctoral degree it could be
i got a great job offering this new town
or
i'm finally selling my car because i
can't do this anymore
there is
financial infidelity here he's hiding
money there is hefty car notes wants to
cash out retirement i mean this is just
a disaster hanging on by a threat yeah
on the money side under no circumstances
are you going to cash out any retirement
funds brittany please if you're
listening uh don't do this what it's
what's going to happen is he needs to
take five jobs clean up this debt
probably sell the car drive a beater get
rid of this 20k and credit card debt and
you guys are gonna get on the same page
you need to become a team here this is
not his problem your problem this is
you all's problem this is we i'd be
willing to bet george that he is telling
his buddies my wife's about to quit her
full-time job and just go back to
college
and in some ways he might be right
that we're having these money challenges
we're having this challenges we're not
on the same page this is a relationship
that's not on the same page and this is
a relationship that has way bigger holes
in the boat than you think they do yeah
so
turn the lights on stop the dance music
somebody's gotta call this thing and you
gotta go see a marriage counselor asap
this sucker's on life support yeah it's
less of a financial question and more of
a relationship question the house is on
fire but do not cash out retirement and
this can be cleaned up but i'm more
concerned about the marriage than i am
the financial components that's right
absolutely all right let's go to scott
in kansas city hey brother scott what's
going on man
hey um kind of nervous here hey we are
too we don't we don't know what we're
doing out of our minds yeah what's up
man i got
dr john i got a question for you it's
been
long hard road we got uh
we got eight kids we got two biological
kids and we adopted the last six
um the two
biological girls they're both out of
school and out of the house you know and
really successful and stuff really doing
a good job uh
problem we got now is the next two in
mind the 16 and 14 year old boys they
just lie constant
i mean it's just heartbreaking we've had
them since
we've had them for 13 years
and um
they're we went to counselors for the
last six seven years you know once a
week and
we went through i don't know how many
counselors six seven eight of them i
don't know
they go
to one during the school now since
school's reopened and stuff and
once a week at least it's not twice
was going to one
during the week ourselves
quite a ways away and then every six
weeks we meet with the main counselor
and uh
it just never-ending i mean we've done
medication and we've done
all kinds of stuff but the lying like
one of them said you know one of the
doctors said there's no magic pill
you know to make it stop but
what how how do you get
to where
you get them from lying
i mean how do you make the lying stop i
mean it's so hard i mean you can't trust
them so let's how old are they again
16 and 14.
so in 30 seconds
you told me a lot of stuff that
communicates your kids have a lot of
problems
that they are
costing you a lot of money a lot of your
time they're taking a lot of your soul
from you what's good about these boys
it's a
well they're very hard workers they
whenever they're
achievement-based brother that's
achievement-based they produce well they
what do you know they love you well i'm
trying
whenever they love you they love you but
whenever they get mad i mean it's it's
mad okay um they have a t that not just
adhd
i can deal with that because i'm that
myself yeah but like the oppositional
divine disorder you know the todd and
then the the attachment disorder the
attachment disorder just breaks a
person's heart right
you know it seems like once we just got
back from a week vacation down there in
disney and universal and it's like they
couldn't even enjoy the harry potter
thing they're humongous harry potter
fans they couldn't even enjoy it because
they're just fighting with each other he
was going to ride this first
and they just kicking each other and
elbowing each other like you guys really
ought to just
be kicked out of here you know really
what do boundaries look like in your
house
i'm assuming that for the last
13 years you all have established pretty
firm boundaries
oh yes you know i mean we've grounded
and everything else and you know and
then
we've disciplined with the spankings
with the taking away stuff and
everything it just don't seem like
anything does any good um the 16 year
old he's
um
he
really uh likes to
accomplish stuff you know with work and
everything he's been mowing yards and 14
year old has been to been mowing some
yards and stuff and got him another job
even starting here today and stuff to
where he's not listening to me
whatsoever and my wife he's not
listening to us whatsoever he just
thinks that we're just you know trying
to sabotage him
but
just try to give you an example the
other day they was doing a trap shoot
practice because they're not interested
in baseball and basketball and stuff so
anyways but we go hunting and they do
we're trying to get them involved with
the trap shoot well anyways i wasn't
down there with a 16 year old i thought
they could drive himself anyways
coming up against the clock so so gets
there to the end of it well it's just
like the coach said you know he will not
listen yeah and finally had just made
him quit
you know and the coach and the parent
you know had to holler at him and
everything else and it's like he don't
even he don't even he don't even
recognize or he will not admit that he
did anything wrong
when's the last time
um
you put that 16 year old boy's head on
your chest and you held put your hand on
his face and you held him for about 30
seconds and said i love you
yesterday
and i try to almost every other day and
i tell you what he just pushes back okay
i mean i don't know if you've ever seen
that attention during the attachment so
i tell you what it is
it's it's super hard it's super hard no
question about that and
there's a
a
express lane in the afterlife
for those who take on foster children
it's hard
and when we look at our kids and so
here's what i'm going to tell you i
can't answer this question in eight
minutes
you've got so many mental health
professionals around you what i want you
to do is to lean in less on
fixing your kids and just doing whatever
you can to connect and i know that's
hard and i know it's a trite answer here
at the end of an hour
lean into connection you've got so many
other things so many other mental health
providers and doctors attachment all
that stuff
your kids your boys need to know dad
loves
not an easy answer my friend and i'm
sorry i can't dig into it more
we'll be right back on the ramsay show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money
your life your relationships
starting new businesses closing
businesses
anything and everything triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john delony joined here by best-selling
author and all-around rock star
wife mom business owner everything
kristy right how are you i'm great i'm
gonna tell matt i'm a rock star wife i
just got introduced on the radio she
just texted that he texted me and said
hey tell her that by the way
please add that to her bio well please
we'll play it how are you uh great i'm
excited because it's a big week and a
lot of energy around here
yeah so tell me about it so tuesday two
days ago book launched it's on the
streets i got to go to target my local
target here and freak out and cause a
big scene for all the employees sign a
few books get excited that it's on an
end capped which by the way it's on end
caps on
target shelves all over the country
hopefully where you are too and then
yesterday did media data mini and then
tonight
is our event me and dave are gonna be
speaking this evening it's a live stream
event and uh and it's really just uh
continuing to
kick off the launch of this book
celebrating you know
the thing is john launching a book in
this world the the reality of our day is
very different now i mean when i
launched business boutique in 2017 it
was a two and a half week book tour
you've got a bus that's wrapped you're
in cities all over the country you know
day after day after day meeting people
signing books shaking hands taking
pictures and gosh it feels a little
different now you know because it's from
here and uh it's all virtual so there's
a sad component to it but at the same
time uh we're making the most of it so
i'm super excited we're gonna have an
in-studio audience here
so if anyone wants to come there's still
tickets to come be with us in person i
will sign every book i will shake your
hand and take pictures which will be fun
but everyone else can join us on live
stream and uh and we're gonna i'm gonna
go through an overview of the book uh
basically my talk is kind of a summary
overview of the book and i've heard the
talk it's and and it's extraordinary
well thank you it hits a nerve which is
funny i i love how dave ramsey opens the
forward of this
and the opening lines of the book of the
forward he writes i tried to talk her
out of it
anybody that knows me knows that's
really not that surprising i would love
to see you all too going back and forth
on that in case you can imagine dave and
christy disagreeing is like watching a
fireworks show inside
it makes tyler seymour my brand manager
have miniature panic attacks every
crisis and disorder for a living and it
makes me
we enjoy it we're like wow we're bonding
we're closer
i walk out of the room i'm like gosh we
just communicated the rest of our hair
is on fire we're breathing smoke and
it's like whoa
everyone doesn't see conflict as
connection like any roommates do well
listen as your friend i'm just so
excited um
i can't my book i think is in a couple
of gas stations across america and so to
walk into a target where they have
lights on and air conditioning just
seems so cool
but congratulations on this it's such an
important book and an important moment
in history thank you everybody is
completely cooked and fried and spun out
and i'm so glad you're doing the event
tonight and um man we are rooting and
cheering you on this awesome thank you
that's one of the fun things about our
company ramsey solutions whether it's
money obviously what we're most known
for anxiety which is what you obviously
have a book on and even with this issue
of time management and balance we really
take on
the hard stuff and we take on the stuff
that most people struggle with this is
not a niche topic like oh it's just for
these certain few people that have no
it's everybody struggles with these
things
money anxiety balance and time
management so um i love that we can just
help a lot of people with the stuff that
they struggle with because we've learned
a lot we've struggled with it different
ways and and we want to give hope in
those spaces so if you're if you have
been living in a rock and haven't
listened to this show in the last month
um give people a synopsis kind of walk
them through what inspired you to write
this book what's what's in your heart
and mind on this deal yeah well i most
people know me as the the business coach
so i have spent 10 years being a
business coach i've written a book
business boutique have events all that
stuff and in 10 years of doing this the
number one question that i'm asked is
not a business question it's this
question how do you balance it all and
i've been asked this by men and women
those with kids those without kids
different ages different stages and so
the problem solver in me wants to wants
to lean into that and go okay wow this
is a major pain point for people
but it took on a new level of i guess
urgency when i had three kids in five
years and felt that strain myself and
and what i have found is that we think
the solution
is productivity we think the solution is
i need to multitask i need to work
harder and smarter and wake up earlier
and pour more coffee and have a better
app and have you know multi-task
throughout the day and stay up later
and we're tired
and we don't feel any more balanced and
so i started asking a different question
what if balance isn't something you do
how you balance it all
what if it's something you could create
in your life and still be busy what if
you could be balanced in an out of
balance world and what if balance
looks more like peace being confident in
your choices
being happy with how you spend your time
i think that's what we're really after
when we say we want to be balanced or we
want to have balance and so i really
believe that comes down to doing the
right things the right time it's not
about doing everything for an equal
amount of time it's about doing the
right things at the right time and when
you do that
you feel that sense of balance you've
been looking for i've we've talked about
this book a number of times and i've
i've just heard you say something i've
never heard you say before
i always feel like if i'm quote unquote
balanced let me take this to like the
weight room if i'm doing a balance
exercise i can't lift super heavy weight
and sometimes when i'm doing these
little balancy exercises doesn't feel
like i really got anything done right
and if i'm a hard charger if i'm a rock
star mom of three and i'm crushing it
and killing it and whatever if i'm a ceo
if i'm uh
over the road truck driver and i'm
putting in extra hours to fill in the
blank
when i hear the word balance
it makes me feel like
don't work as hard yeah that's why dave
hates the word okay that's why he to him
it is the phone calls he's had for 30
years where someone says well i can't
pay off my debt because i just you know
i love my kids and i don't want to take
a second job i don't want to work so
hard that's what he hears gotcha and i
think that's what a lot of us here right
yeah and what's and i think we just we
we swing to these extremes like oh
you've got to live in this zen state and
meditate all day like no that's
ridiculous that's not anything or you
got to be slaughtered and murdered right
right i think i think we think of this
um idea that that everything is going to
be equal we're going to do it all well
so for example let's say that you have a
week and the right thing for you to do
that week is busted at work that's the
season i'm in right now i'm launching a
book i'm today i got here six this
morning i'll be here till nine tonight
that's right today
but if i judge myself like oh like did i
work out today no am i hanging out with
my friends today no did i slow down and
have time to myself no there's all these
things i didn't do but if you come by
with your kids this morning no sure did
not right um
and so if i judge myself on my success
in the areas i'm not spending time on on
a day that i'm spending time on
something else well then all i come up
with every time is that i'm failing
failure and so there are millions of
people walking around every day feeling
like they're failing they're actually
not they're doing the right things
they're just focusing on the thing
they're not doing and so i want to help
you determine what's right right now
and then acknowledge that it's right and
be proud of the fact that you're doing
what's right and so it's both it's it's
both i want to spend my time on the
right things but then even if you do it
you still need to be present for it and
be proud of it instead of feeling guilty
for all these things that are not right
right now so it's both uh tactical but
also there's an uh emotional aspect of
it too it's almost a it's a
psychological and spiritual component
yeah be where you are and become present
and be really excited to be there yeah
that's what a
timely message for a chaotic world yeah
thank you for putting this out into the
world thank you christy wright her new
book take back your time
and target on the internets everywhere
chrissyright.com rachel ramsey
solutions.com is gonna say rachel or
rachel or rachel send rachel to send you
there she'll buy it too right
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
foreign
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john delony joined by my good friend and
wrestling author christy wright taking
your calls on money life balance
relationships all of it let's go to nick
in lexington kentucky what's up brother
nick
not much how are you all outstanding
brother what's up how can we help
well first off thank you all for taking
my call on christy john everybody from
the whole ramsey solution you guys have
been a lot of inspiration and me and my
family and
just thank you all for what you're doing
and just keep on you've helped us out a
ton that's awesome guys appreciate you
first off i'm i'm 33 my wife's 30.
we've been married about eight years
we've got a four-year-old girl and a
one-year-old girl
about four years ago we started uh doing
the ramsay playing great uh davish
uh went about 18 months and really well
kind of backed off for a year uh jumped
back in it about 18 months ago
so we've been at it for about three
years now we've got
right at 66 000 worth of debt paid off
congratulations
we're down to our last 2
should be done by the end of this month
yeah
and you survived a hurricane of
two little kids in that house that's
phenomenal brother
yes yes she's been awesome throughout
this whole time so cool my question to
you all is now that we kind of see that
light at the end of the tunnel i i know
once we we hit that 2000 and get that
taken away we have everything gone but
the house
i know we go back in to
start putting away in retirement but
you know we like to camp we like to ride
we like to uh you know have people what
we're thinking about wanting to kind of
build this detached garage
we want to kind of upgrade the camper
at what point
do we say
we can start doing that
well it's you know you can do those
things once you have obviously the money
for them but we still there's one more
baby step that we want you to be intense
on and that's baby step three and that's
where you get your three to six months
of expenses so even after you pay off
your debt this month which is a huge
accomplishment don't take your foot off
the gas just yet you want to figure out
how much money do you need to have three
to six months of expenses and that's
what we would call a fully funded
emergency fund if something major
happened to the house to the car to a
health issue whatever
then you've got that emergency fund
where you're not scared you're not good
or not scared from the money side of it
you're not going to go into debt to
cover it and then once you get past baby
step three and you have that fully
funded emergency fund you will move into
four five and six that is where
it's more of a steady marathon you're
doing them simultaneously you're
investing 15 percent you're saving for
kids college and you're paying off your
house and these are all happening at the
same time it's more gradual it's over a
long haul so it's not the same gazelle
intensity you have in baby step two or
even three and that's where yeah you can
save up and cash flow those things but
what you're gonna need to do nick and
this is hard
is when you get to that stage you and
your wife are gonna need to sit down and
talk about which do we wanna do first
matt and i have these conversations john
it's like oh which do we wanna do do we
want to get a new ac unit or do we want
to take a vacation
you know and you just have to think
through like how urgent is this and
which one the camper or the trip or
whatever and
and
you just prioritize it as simple and
tactical as that is you all have a
conversation and decide about what you
want to do first in what order you save
up and pay cash and cash flow those
things and nick i've seen this
conversation go one of two ways
it is a
grind you'll go on a date and it turns
into a well i've been wanting to do this
and i've been wanting to do that
and what you try to do is you try to map
out these things that you want to get
and attach to your old life
the other way i've seen this thing go
and this is the way i hope you will go
i hope you and your wife will celebrate
this extraordinary accomplishment you
guys have you just have done really
remarkable things you do you've done a
very rare thing you're in rare air now
and you'll take a half day and you'll
get away from the kids you get a
babysitter you'll go get a nice
breakfast maybe a progressive breakfast
or eat one thing here and drive over and
go eat somewhere do something cool and
consider a miniature retreat
and begin to think about where do we
want to be
who do we want to be what is that going
to look like and that becomes a dream
conversation a fun conversation
inspiring conversation and not a well i
want a camper well i want an outdoor air
conditioner and i want a garage it
becomes a what kind of people are we
gonna be and i don't know about you
christy when i when i got to
the baby step three part these things i
thought i wanted they took on less and
less importance the freer i got yeah it
was this weird attachment i had to stuff
and i didn't realize it was a security
blanket yeah right and so then when i
didn't know anybody anything and you're
looking around thinking
oh well i'm just i don't know we'll get
that later i don't know it just kind of
it kind of let the air out of some of
that stuff you know it's so funny you
say that because um
in the book i actually quote craig
rochelle in a similar question that you
just said because often we don't know
what to do on our calendar we don't know
what to put on our schedule and so you
ask yourself that exact question you
just said who do i want to be yeah and
he says this craig gersell says when you
know who
you'll know what to do and so ask
yourself who do i want to be and let
that inform your money who do i want to
be let that inform what you put on your
calendar because you're going to put
things on your calendar that allow you
to be the person you want to be and
you're going to buy the stuff or
prioritize the purchases that are in
line with who you are it's such a better
question i love that you asked that well
in in for nick it might be
we want to be a camp and family we want
to be an outdoor adventure family and
for the next 24 months we're gonna be
koa folks yeah and koa's awesome we're
gonna get a small cabin and we're gonna
be saving up and saving up and get this
dream camper or whatever that looks like
right but it's instead of i want that i
want that i want that it's yeah who are
we gonna be so good all right hey
danielle in asheville what is going on
danielle
and hello can you hear me we can what's
up hi hi thank you for taking my call i
just have a quick question
i have a problem i cannot say no
to anybody really but my kids my mom um
me and my husband my husband is on the
road two months at a time he's a leaf
operator truck driver and i work for
astronautics
and um
we're just we're in baby step two we
have about
10 000 left in collections to pay off
and then we'll be debt-free
um but the problem is we are now a human
atm like
i don't know how to stop it like i
we i was brought up poor
out of my mom was a single mom so i feel
like i can never let her do without
because
she never let me she worked really hard
for me to have
you know a life that i did have
yeah
danielle one of the things that i think
you're in tune with which i think is
really good
is why you struggle with saying no like
you even just hit on it right there like
well you sort of feel indebted to your
mom she you know all these things and
what she did for you and so and so when
you begin to understand your deeper
motivations you can dig into that and
start to work on it there so i think
that's one of the things that's helpful
but i'll just since we don't have a ton
of time to dig into all aspects i'll
just give you a quick tip that i help
people with this all the time on saying
no this is a hot topic with time
management or anything for that matter
um certainly money
it takes practice
it takes practice it's like a muscle if
you never exercise that muscle that
muscle is weak and wobbly at first but
the more you exercise it the stronger
that muscle becomes the more you can do
it that the easier it becomes so even if
that means danielle you literally sit
down and you write out where someone
asks you for something ask you for money
and you're gonna on your own script out
your response what would you say in that
situation you practice in front of your
mirror practice in front of your dog i
don't care i know this sounds silly but
then the next time you get asked that
question you don't feel so put on the
spot you deliver that line and you just
practice doing it it's going to be a
little awkward at first but with
practice i think it does get easier and
danielle i'm somebody who
has tried to
earn love over the course of my life try
to achieve it as though it's something i
can buy if i just say yes if i keep
showing up i keep showing up keep you
showing up and what ended up happening
was i would begin to show up
ungrateful i'd show up resenting the
fact that i was even there i'd show up
exhausted and peop everyone around me
started getting the my second third and
fourth fruits especially
my wife and kids when you got a husband
that's on the road sometimes it's
tempting to try to
buy your children's joy right out of
guilt so a phrase that's made its way
around the mental health community over
the last couple of years that i love
is choose guilt over resentment
choose guilt over resentment i would
rather you
say no and feel that in your body as
guilt when your kid says hey can we go
to sonic can we get to this can we do
this and you say no we're not doing that
today we need healthy we need a home
and you feel that guilt
then to drive all the way to sonic with
your kids in the back resenting the fact
that you can't say no and that shame and
your kids are annoying i can't believe
i'm letting them do this and drive all
the way home and then all night choose
guilt over resentment every single time
and as christie says as you practice it
you'll begin to feel less guilty you'll
stand a little bit taller and suddenly
you'll find yourself saying no with a
smile on your face and it will bring joy
to everyone around you this is the
ramsay show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show i'm john
delonie joined by my good friend christy
wright taking your calls on life work
relationships
money all of it
and on the debt-free stage we don't have
a debt-free screen but we have an
in-house question our friend mike from
fair banks alaska what's going on
brother mike
yes thank you um
question up front i don't know how to
charge people
get over that hurdle of
thinking my what my time is worth and
for actually charging for my time now
the that's the question up front the
context of that is i'll be retiring
next month
and so kind of want to do a dream i've
had for many years and now with the
retirement i'll have a basement on how
much comes in
so the risk is is is gone that used to
be there if i was just to quit
so i have all the skills to do what i
want to do so when you say a basement
you mean you're going to have retirement
coming in yeah okay so there'll be a low
a lowest you know with food and covering
we'll be content so we have the money
okay but from up there um i'd like to
add
income with uh with some light remodel
type work so i have all the skills built
our own house done major gut job
remodels on places i've owned but and i
have done some work for other people not
pay but just to help them out so the
skills are there
but
i've never been in a position where i
have to charge someone
for what i'm doing and i'll probably
underprice myself i'll probably feel
guilty saying this is
this is what your materials are going to
cost now this is what i'm going to cost
because i'm my business plan is to let
them pay for the materials so i'm not
their banker
and then i just charge them for my labor
so um
anyway any thoughts on
how to get over that hurdle yeah you
know first of all i just want to
encourage you that this is a really
common
struggle
for people starting out in business it's
a really common struggle for people in
service-based businesses where you're
charging for your time not necessarily
i'm going to sell you a t-shirt you're
paying for the t-shirt that's a little
bit more removed from the person um so i
just want to encourage you it's common
and it can be overcome people do it all
day every day it's kind of similar to
what we were talking about a minute ago
with saying no being a muscle through
practice the more you talk about it it
will be easier but here's what i want
you to think about so when you think
about it as your business
sometimes we get all squirmy like oh i
feel bad this is something you've done
without charging before so it's kind of
in your brain as a hobby a gift doing
something to be nice so it's been in
this category
you also already have income so it's not
like this is primary source of income so
that income feels like well i don't
really have to charge
what i want to help do help you do and
you can think about this is i want you
to mentally shift this business idea
from being a hobby
to being a business because a hobby
costs you money and a business makes you
money
if this is going to be a business
this the purpose of this
is to make money that's actually what we
do in business we serve the marketplace
they pay us
certificates of appreciation with
presidents faces on them so when you
switch this into that mental gear of
okay the purpose of this is to make
money then it takes a little bit of your
feelings out of it because it's not
about you it's about the business this
business needs to make money in order to
stay
in business
one other thing that can help you
because so much of it is in our head in
addition to the practice one other thing
that might help you mike because i want
you to think about
think about something that you have paid
for recently just tell me anything it
could be a product or a service what's
something you've paid for recently that
you really liked that you really were
happy you bought
we're all plane tickets okay plane
tickets plaintiff i was thinking of
those incredible carhartt pants i'd hire
you right now based on the car hearts
man those are awesome car hearts i love
it okay so plane tickets right you you
paid for plane tickets because there was
a value
in that service and that in being able
to have a flight
so you would rather have the flight than
that amount of money you paid for it and
the airline company would rather have
your money than than the expense it cost
them to to run that flight
when you take the emotion out of it and
you see that sales is just an exchange
of value
it makes it a little bit easier to
charge not perfectly easy again it's
going to take practice but you think
this is not about you mike the person
this is about there's a value
of the renovation you're doing there's a
value of the home improvements you're
doing i just had our deck stained at our
house and i even wrestled with like oh
could we do it ourselves because we're
do-it-yourselfers to save the money and
we just no let's let's pay someone we've
got three little kids when are we gonna
do it and this awesome man he's a friend
of ours he's a handyman came over did
that it's an outstanding job way better
than we would have ever done
i was thrilled to pay that money because
there's a value in the service he
provided so just a couple quick tips for
you on think of it as a business not a
hobby
and think of when you're a consumer
and you pay for something you're glad
you paid for that's how customers are
going to see you there's a value in the
service you provide and and it's going
to take some practice it's going to take
some practice look in the marketplace
what are other people charging for home
renovations you structure the business
and the
charging the way that you want to but i
think that the first one will be the
hardest the second one will be a little
easier third will be a little easier
over time it will get easier so i read a
book recently i'm kind of a nerd and uh
i don't have a lot of friends but i read
a lot the book is called chatter by
ethan cross and one of the big takeaways
he's a professor from university of
michigan
talked about how we activate our
fight-or-flight responses how we
activate some of our natural fear
responses
and interestingly when we say the words
and this is right alongside this is like
some neuroscience
that validates it
with some science john i mean
that when we say things like i and we
i'm it's the reason why you might be
thinking i don't know why i can't seem
to communicate with my wife today i i'm
missing the boat here your heart starts
racing you get that pit in your stomach
you get that headache your back hurts
but when your buddy calls you and says
hey can you help me with my marriage
you're able to rattle off well yeah ding
dong do one two and three when we talk
to ourselves in third person
for some reason it doesn't activate our
bodies it doesn't get that shame that
worth that
i should be doing this for free i'm a
good guy i have a faith component i'm a
person of faith and we should just give
everything away because that's what you
know
i wonder if you talked about um this is
about the business i wonder if you can
separate yourself and not say what
should i charge because now your body's
going to respond because this is an
identity issue
instead of saying what should mike
charge for that
mike should charge 250 or 2500 for that
that's a fair price and your body will
not get as emotionally invested it won't
fire off the cortisol and the adrenaline
to try to protect you from you or from
the shame or from the rejection that
you're going to experience and that's
another key component here people are
going to tell you sorry we can't afford
that right now or
we took another bid and what you're
going to have to do is really practice
not letting that say that means mike's
lame or mike's not a good guy or mike's
a bad guy or mike does probably work
overtime that's going to give you data
about your pricing and your value and
what kind of work you do but not
internalizing sure right and weighing on
you but i love i love i love that you
are retiring and heading to something
one of the things we see often folks
retire
and then they just want to prop their
feets up feed up and just do nothing and
man then then
our bodies fall apart on us our minds
fell upon us so that is you're going to
continue to give gifts to other people
and yourself and that's incredible well
and just know mike too that if you start
out and you price a little too low out
of the gate you can increase your prices
and you will and people do and that's
normal so don't put all this pressure on
yourself to come out with the perfect
price out of the gate start with
something that you can say with
confidence and then as your confidence
builds your prices can increase and
you'll you'll get those muscles
strengthened but that's so fascinating
you can even name the business call it
mike's home renovations well mike's home
renovation charges this as if you're not
even mike that's good you're just
representing mike's home renovations and
just so you know like so when i go speak
at certain events like i have a
speaker's fee that runs through ramsey
and businesses and and colleges whatever
bring me in to speak
this past weekend i did a particular
event at a newer
group with a new group so i actually
charged less because it was going to be
a different type of talk for me it was
going to be a different and so i'm
helping them with the price but it's
also a beta for me right i'm practicing
new old material in a new place or new
material in a different place and so
it's okay if you normally do
cabinetry and somebody asked you for a
fence to say i'm going to give you a
little bit lower rate i'm going to learn
this and then after this i can say i do
fences too right so everybody's winning
in this thing yeah excellent absolute
advice but uh thank you so so much for
that question yeah let us know how it
goes report back when you do it thank
you i love that i love you man um
christy you talk you have that
conversation all the time all the time
it's about value yeah
it's not about you it's the value i
think you go get coffee at starbucks or
somewhere i want the coffee more than my
five dollars they want my five dollars
it's an exchange of value take all your
feelings out of it there's a there's a
value in what you're doing and people
are willing to pay for that value oh i
love that what would christy charge for
this or what would john do you know what
john should john charge for this not
what should i charge right yes so fast
we'll be right back on the ramsay show
so
today's scripture is john 8 12. jesus
said i am the light of the world whoever
follows me will never walk in darkness
but will have the light of the world
mark twain says the two most important
days in your life are the day you are
born and the day you find out why
man i love mark twain it's pretty deep i
mean we can camp there for a while
all right let's go to ruth in san
antonio hey ruth what's going on
oh well i'm a big dave brimsy person and
i have your book and listened to a
couple of times
uh recently back in january i have been
taking care of my mother who had
dementia for two and a half years
unfortunately she developed coveted and
passed away in january i'm sorry and i'm
excuse me i'm trying not to get upset
no you're good i'm
i'm the executor of the estate
and i have
two siblings that are making it very
hard for me they're you know you should
have done this you should have done that
and
recently they're accusing me of stealing
money from my mother and uh
i'm not really sure how to handle it and
like i've requested bank statements so i
can go back and say oh hey look here's
where this money is here's where this
money is and
it it's kind of funny because for two
and a half years they said nothing no
one ever came to see her it was up to me
to take her to see them
and now it's
well you know
and so that's kind of my terrible story
oh i'm so sorry yeah i'm so sorry so
ruth a couple of things here number one
i'm so sorry about the loss of your mom
um
have you had a chance to exhale and sit
in that
i had good days and bad days and
yesterday was a bad day because i had to
hang up on her because she was telling
me that she hoped
i could live with myself and that god
could forgive
pray for god to forgive me for what i've
done to the family and i'm like i took
care of my mother that's right so bad so
um listen you are not solving a math
problem here
this is not a forensic issue
i'm gonna give your brother and sister
the benefit of the doubt and
say that i'm gonna assume they are
struggling with guilt over not being
there for mom that they are heartbroken
that their mom's gone
that every time they see something on tv
about another cova death or another
thousand kova deaths or
that brings up mom
and they are choosing unfortunately to
channel that guilt and anger and sadness
and heartbreak at you
do you deserve that no and again i'm
giving them the high benefit the doubt
the the low benefit of that is their
jerks and their complete scumbags and
they went and had a drink one night
together and thought hey man let's get
our hands on some of mom's money
i don't want to go there
but you can go get bank statements and
do forensic accounting and all that kind
of stuff i wouldn't spend my energy on
that unless they sue you
what you're trying to do is prove
yourself to you
and you don't need to do that
often when people are taking care of
folks
who have dementia
you watch the most important person in
your life slowly
slip away
and it's really painful because it's
like a slow motion accident and it just
slips through your fingers
and it's almost a slow-motion trauma
right and it it weighs on your personal
relationships your finances your time
and you live in fight-or-flight for a
couple of years and then you finally
wake up and you realize your identity is
different you don't know where you are
what i should be doing because i've been
having to keep somebody else
alive and okay for the last couple years
and that's why i ask you if you sad in
it not in your brother and sister
situation but
in i lost my mom
and it's heartbreaking and then the two
people that you would hope would rally
around you
are not they're forming an alliance
against you and you find yourself
totally alone
and
it's really sad because there's no
gratitude
at all i know but listen listen
you're using your grief
and your sadness
and you're looking for people to channel
that on
what i'm going to ask you to do is to
forgive your brother and sister stop
responding to them and move on
your mom chose you for a reason it may
be just why what we're seeing right now
why she chose you
because she knew they were immature and
they were um not people of integrity and
so she chose you
to handle the estate
have you done right by that estate
yes have you ever stolen a dime
did you honor your mother in her last
few years
yes
then i want you to go to sleep with
peace in your heart your brother and
sister no longer get a vote and that's
hard to say they no longer get a vote
and i want you to forgive them and stop
taking those calls stop taking the abuse
stop
giving yourself other jobs in order to
make people who are not well and who are
taking crap out on you to try to make
them happy because you're not it's it's
throwing water into an endless well
you'll never fill it up
you did right ruth and now it's time to
grieve your mom and then come up with
the next chapter of ruth's life which
unfortunately is not going to include
your brother and sister for the time
being right yeah ruth i have to tell you
i have unfortunately had a front row
seat to watch this happen to different
different families that i know
and
this exact process losing a parent the
executor of the will the siblings
involved can bring out the absolute
worst in some people and people that you
thought were so close before that
happened are no longer close and it is a
sad thing to watch
it's a sad thing to experience but the
one thing i would offer
uh as an encouragement piggybacking on
what john said which is so true is
their behavior says something about them
not about you
you ha you know what you have done and
not done
you were chosen for this you have not
stolen money just like you just said you
have done right by her and you're going
to stand on that and you're not going to
let any of their emails their texts
their calls their accusations their
hateful words that they are spewing at
you you're going to stand on the truth
of who you are and what you know and
what you have done
and just like john said let that give
you peace tonight because the way that
they're acting says something about them
it's not a reflection of you
this is hard hard hard ruth
oh it is and i've been taking your
advice i'm exercising again i've even
signed up for a half marathon
that's awesome
discovered this grace for purpose on
youtube and i listen to that a bunch you
know and i'm trying to get back to that
point and it's it's helped a lot but
then when someone throws a new thing at
you you go okay so i ate some cookies
today
hey you know what it's it's we all need
some cookies every now and then that's
exactly right
um
grieving the loss of our parents is hard
it's hard it's not easy the path is hard
and it's especially hard when people we
love throw rocks at us along the way
and it shouldn't be that way
and unfortunately it is
and it's time to grieve that loss and
your brothers and sisters unfortunately
and they no longer get a vote
i'm proud of you i'm so proud of you for
stepping up and doing the the
debate what i call the basics right
taking care of your body and your mind
and
your you know entertaining optimistic
choices about i'm gonna i'm gonna
discover a new purpose right that's
awesome so great
and here here's
we only have a few minutes left so i
won't just get on a soapbox okay but if
you
are struggling in your grief if you lost
someone that you care about which there
have been a lot of loss now 24 months
if
you're feeling shame or guilt or what
you didn't say or did say or what i
didn't do or how
don't take that out on somebody else
don't weaponize your grief and hurt
somebody else because you're hurting
yeah have the courage to say i'm sad
how could you help someone
identify that they're doing that
any time sometimes i'm thinking most
people probably don't realize they're
doing it or are intentionally doing it
when you find yourself enraged or angry
at somebody that you should otherwise
love
that's a that's a moment for you to step
back
and take a breath and ask this question
i got this from my
my good friend jordan bunch he worked
for me once and um
i asked him once just as his supervisor
how are you always so
moving through the world so lightly and
he said every time i have a problem i
first look in the mirror and say jordan
would you contribute to this and so i
have taken that with me forever and
sometimes i overdo it and i take on too
much sure but as somebody who is prone
to blame and prone to point fingers it's
been a it's been an extraordinary
exercise for last 10 or 15 years to look
in the mirror and say what am i
contributing to this so
if you are leaning against your brother
or your sister and mom just died and you
were enraged at why didn't they you
should have look in the mirror and say
is it me that's hurting here
and does it really matter yeah because i
miss my sister right yeah so that's just
a that's just an idea ruth we're so
grateful for you i want to thank james
childs and kelly daniel for running the
show and keeping things rocking and
rolling actually kelly's name here we
got jenna in the booth jenna thank you
so much hey we love being with you we'll
see you next time on the ramsay show
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
you